[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Наддніпрянщина
Макарів]
Я думаю: «Як мені зварити Чужого?»
Сів, передивився весь Youtube,
знайшов відео, де хлопці його робили
для Стівена Спілберга,
[Володимир Вавілов
Автоконструктор-самоук]
знайшов майстерню.
Думаю: «Ой лишенько!»
Їх там 25 чоловік.
Це є умови, фінансування.
Я думав, що я його не зроблю.
А потім думаю: «Я його обов'язково зроблю!
Тут немає чого робити».
Тільки так я його зробив.
Коли я йду вулицями і бачу гарні автомобілі,
то думаю, що ніколи не зможу купити таку машину,
а от зробити своїми силами я щось можу.
Я почав робити, і тепер
коли я дивлюся на подібні автомобілі,
мені зовсім вони нецікаві,
тому що таких машин
є тисячі на світі, а моя — одна.
На зелене світло, коли ми тягнемо і стоїмо,
то на зелене світло навіть не всі їдуть.
Люди вискакують із фотоапаратами,
залишаються машини на перехрестях.
Почав я будувати у 2015 році,
купив польський Fiat.
Зробив я таку маленьку машину з двигуном 1,6 л від Volkswagen Passat,
а потім думаю: «Що ж я роблю, вкладаю гроші,
а в результаті буде звичайна машина».
І я вирішив зробити більшу машину.
Купив BMW 730, поставив двигун ззаду.
Потім я почав робити кузов,
і машина стала схожа
на автомобіль із майбутнього,
у ній з'явився космічний образ.
Коли я зробив космічний образ,
то спало на думку причепити
згори космічний корабель.
І після того, як я причепив космічний корабель —
я подивився, що тут ще чогось не вистачає.
І вирішив причепити чудовисько,
як у фільмі «Чужий».
Потім я причепив йому ще такий ось кулемет,
і машина стала дуже цікава,
і почала подобатись людям.
Ззаду я зробив ось отакі речі.
Це машина — музична,
тобто всюди стоять ось такі динаміки.
Потім будеш на кнопочку тут натискати,
і буде підніматись догори
оця вся задня частина,
і там — ліжко, туди можна заходити.
На кожен циліндр виведена труба вихлопу:
коли воно запуститься, буде дуже цікавий звук.
Тут ще на рік роботи.
Ця машина зроблена на 30 відсотків, і вона тоді буде зовсім-зовсім інша.
Ось так буде ставати космічний корабель,
тут будуть піротехнічні засоби, і буде давати салют.
Тут діти фотографуються,
це їхнє улюблене місце.
Все буде в ілюмінації, тут все світиться.
На габаритних вогнях —
близько двох тисяч різних лампочок.
Будуть крутитись стовбури,
це буде також крутитись,
оце поліцейський рупор —
можна якісь оголошення робити.
Кулемет буде повертатись на всі сторони,
тут буде магнітола.
На дистанційному управлінні він у мене буде говорити космічним голосом те, що я захочу.
Тут має бути як у гелікоптері,
тут буде все в тумблерах,
бо в автомобілі дуже багато
різних застосувань:
голова буде повертатися,
буде вібратор стояти у нього в животі,
який буде трусити машину,
як той павук, коли мені буде потрібно.
Шість відеокамер, дванадцять телевізорів
по всій машині.
Продубльовані будуть дзеркала у кабіні на моніторах.
Потім «Чужий» буде весь в облуді,
на ньому буде луска як у кіно,
ми не будемо бачити оці всі дроти,
це все буде в зовсім іншому вигляді.
Машина не на ходу, на жаль,
не вистачає трохи коштів, щоб вона поїхала.
Якби вона була на ходу,
то вона б уже була у Стівена Спілберга.
Поліцейські мене полюбили.
Цікаво, що всі мені казали:
«Тільки ти виїдеш на дорогу,
тут же поліцейські тебе зупинять!»
Сталася зовсім інша історія:
всі поліцейські проїжджають
ось так [роблять знімки] з телефонами,
ніхто ще не зупиняв, а якщо зупиняють, то:
— Дозвольте сфотографуватись?
— Я не маю документів.
«Вам документи не потрібні,
дайте хоч до неї доторкнутися».
Був я в інституті для того, щоб перероблювати автомобіль: «Давайте ж якось узаконимо».
«Ми перед вами схиляємо голови, але нічого вам дозволити не можемо, все порушено.
Це нереально зробити у нас в Україні».
Тому її вихід такий: її або тягати іншим автомобілем,
або її вантажити на лафет, і перевозити її,
і там щоб вона вже їздила своїм ходом.
Я закінчив училище ім. Глієра
і інститут Поплавського,
я сам — колишній музикант, грав на акордеоні.
Моя основна робота — не автомобіль, і не залізо,
я — майстер по дереву.
Я почав деревом займатись ще у 1993 році.
У мене багато робіт різних:
я зробив близько п'ятидесяти
простих більярдів, мабуть.
Оце в 2011 році я почав робити ножки,
але не маю часу закінчити.
Ось на одну таку ніжку
в мене пішов один місяць.
Він же знову ж таки — музичний:
шар буде падати, замикатиме контакт,
у цей час буде засвічуватись
світло по всьому більярду, включатиметься музика,
і над ним буде висіти лампа, така старовинна буде фортеця висіти.
Жінка говорить: «Переросла дитина».
Мені вже 53 роки, але я іще
не досяг того, що я планую.
Довелось заплатити сім'єю за цю машину.
Сім'я не розуміє, жінка не розуміє,
не поділяє мої думки з цього приводу.
Врешті решт, це все було зроблено,
щоб сім'я мала статки,
і щоб вони побачили,
що я можу щось таке зробити.
Я був на автошоу «Old car land»,
її поставили при вході там,
люди далі не йшли на автошоу,
а так натовп людей просто так і залишався,
і тоді, звісно, в мене виросли крила.
Я зрозумів, що це саме те,
і що нічого цікавого, крім моєї машини,
я більше не бачу.
Я зараз жодній іншій машині не заздрю.
До мене приходило сюди
дуже багато людей різних, і казали:
«Володю, ти що з глузду з'їхав?
Тобі немає чим займатись?
Покинь цю залізяку, це нікому не треба,
зараз століття технологій: електромобілі полетіли,
і вже люди в космос полетіли.
Покинь! З тебе будуть сміятися люди».
Нікого не треба слухатись! Треба робити те, що ти хочеш! Ти вирішив? Треба робити!
Оце тільки по такому принципу треба діяти,
тому що скільки людей — стільки і думок, розумієте?
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Субтитрувальниця
Оля Стулій]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]